by now you've probably heard the term
annual enrollment period but what does
that mean and what do you or your family
members need to know about it here to
explain is neil booth principal of
medicare by ama hello neil hi how are
you i am wonderful especially after
looking at this spread that you brought
here for us today what is this all about
well you're wondering why this is about
medicare well we do medicare mondays
where we invite members of the public to
come into our local store at the
medicare resource center and learn all
about medicare every monday 10 am well
that is a great resource to have now can
you tell me a little bit about medicare
and what you talk about at medicare
mondays absolutely medicare mondays are
really important this time of the year
in the annual enrollment period is where
beneficiaries can make changes to their
medicare plans
now why why is it important to have
something like this for people because
you
a lot of us get very confused on what
that means absolutely it is confusing
and there's so many information out
there that talks about medicare call
this number call this number our agency
or a local agency that provide local
information we have our local licensed
agents in our store
every single day of the week monday to
saturday now that really is important
you hit on a big thing with being local
because i know a lot of people get
overwhelmed with the information and you
call someone nationally they don't
really understand this market they don't
really understand the resources here
and that's why you guys are completely
different absolutely we have those local
relationships for example this year
there's a brand new carrier to nevada
brand new has some great benefits with
things like
zero tier one and two generic
prescriptions even
zero
insulin so there's all this information
that we work locally to make sure
everybody is aware with what's available
and we know the local marketplace our
local licensed agent are there to help
our seniors it really does put you a
step above everyone else but just a
simple question
why is medicare so confusing it's so
confusing because there's many different
moving parts things change every single
year and people think you know they may
have the right coverage for them but not
know what's available the other
confusing part is a lot of people see
these national different adverts et
cetera commercials and think oh i can
get everything but they don't really
understand what's available for them
in their local market here in nevada so
that's why it's important that an agency
like the resource centre
is open and available and we that's why
we do our medicare mondays it's such a
great idea you can go you can have some
treats some refreshments and get the
information that you need on a local
level it's so important neil such great
information thank you so much for
explaining to us you can be a part of
medicare mondays every monday at 10 a.m
through december 6 to find out how you
can get the most out of your medicare
plan and visit the medicare resource
center medicare by ama at 2250 tropicana
avenue suite 4 and for more information
you can call 702-3302
or go to medicare by ama.com
jillian